I was going to say I'm ignorant about
PTSD and I I was under the impression
and probably wrongfully so that it's
from one single event could it just be
like multiple events that have happened
over the time that have caused PTSD now
yes like um and by the way I also
thought it was for combat veterans only
you know and you virtually have been in
combat and that's not even a joke no
even my friends in the military are like
no no you can have it too um but yeah
it's um I think the come culmination of
things for me probably and also like
within that six-year period you know I
lost my mom and my sister and like so it
was a a few things but I I would say
probably the Trump thing mixed with the
cancer mixed with the pill addiction
like probably you put those three why
were you taking the pills they were
painkillers yeah and I just when the
Trump thing happened I just didn't know
what to do with myself all day so what
were the pills oh I took took uppers
downers and
painkillers to so like ad girls which I
call adag girls so I took adag girls I
took which made you feel like what for
what what does that do well wait a
minute here's the best part I wanted to
take them to be
thinner oh no no think of how crazy that
is that once again at 50 I think I was
59 when it and I think you've ever had a
weight no I no and just it's just
embarrassing to even think that's my
very deep reason for taking them but and
then but everyone said it helped their
focus which that wasn't my problem but
the painkillers are just painkillers
because they just literally I should say
ader is an upper Prov aner lose weight
like o probably in a different way it
stomach's way healthier but ader all I
don't want to give anybody ideas don't
do this no don't do this by the way
Aderall is in 12st Step it's been
likened to cocaine so some people think
it is maybe as strong as cocaine or a
pill form of cocaine so basically I was
taking uppers downers which are the
benzos like um Adavan
clopin valian and what was that for so I
could sleep so and then the painkillers
were to kind of just feel like numbed
out were you in pain no how do you get
that I was in mental pain how do you get
that oh okay so this is what's really
weird first of all when you're older
they just give you this stuff that's
second of all I had amess all these
pills that I never took and it's almost
like
mentally I Was preparing for some I was
like a doomsday prepper for prescription
pills I really did I and I once I
started taking them I thought maybe this
is what I kept him around for but no I
do not Advocate this it was bad for me
ended up in a psych
hold
n